i've been using apple's magic keyboard
case for the 11 inch ipad pro for a
couple of months now
and i'm even more impressed with it now
that i've gotten used to using it like
it's meant to be used
it now feels very natural to lift it off
of the case to use it in tablet mode
before placing it back on and getting
instant access to the keyboard and
trackpad
thanks to the smart connector i've now
gotten used to using a combination of
keyboard shortcuts
touch control and the trackpad which
honestly gives you so much freedom and
convenience
that we've never had before with an ipad
and by the way
this trackpad is better than i ever
expected and it's the main reason why i
told people
the magic keyboard case is well worth
the 100 bucks
over the bridge pro plus keyboard case
i've also gotten used to the weight of
the magic keyboard
and i'm very impressed with just how
portable it is
so basically i've realized that right
now
the magic keyboard case is a much bigger
deal than people make it out to be
and based on recent events and rumors i
believe the magic keyboard case is gonna
absolutely blow up very soon and i'm
talking blowing up like the airpods did
if you think about it when the airpods
were first announced
people were mocking them for the
incredibly high price of a hundred and
fifty nine dollars
and now they've gone viral and apple is
selling airpods pro
for 250 dollars and people are loving
them
that's exactly what i think is going to
happen with the magic keyboard case
many people are mocking it and calling
it way overpriced for what it is
saying that they can get an entire ipad
for the price of the case itself
which is true however i think that once
apple fully reveals all of their plans
for the magic keyboard
people are gonna flock to the apple
store to get their hands on one
so let me explain the three reasons why
i think it's gonna get so huge
starting with the upcoming ipad air 4.
but first i want to mention that you
guys can find our apple product
pattern t-shirts right below this video
in the merch shelf
in the last video i made on the ipad air
4 rumors
i gave you guys all of the reasons why i
think apple is gonna give it
the same exact frame or body as the 11
inch ipad pro
and the reason that they would do this
is that so it supports the current
magic keyboard case let me explain the
current gen ipad air
took on the previous design of the 10.5
inch ipad pro
it literally has the same exact body
except for only having speakers on one
side
and it even supports the same keyboard
cases as the pro did
so it wouldn't be unreasonable to
believe that apple would do that again
there were also a lot of mixed leaks and
rumors
pointing to the ipad air 4 having either
an 11 inch or 10.8 inch display
and i think that both of them are
correct the 11 inch rumors
were talking about the body size and the
10.8 inch rumors
were talking about the display they both
make sense if you think of the ipad air
maintaining
a 4x3 aspect ratio so it'll have
slightly larger bezels leading to a
slightly smaller
10.8 inch display other rumors pointed
to the ipad air 4 coming with a usbc
port
just like the ipad pro so if you take
all of that into consideration
it makes the most sense for apple to
just give it the same body as the pro
but limit the features like for example
not having quad speakers
not having the pro motion 120 hertz
display and not having as powerful as a
processor but what it will have
is support for the magic keyboard case
so what apple can do
is sell a bunch of these ipad airs for
500
to a much broader market compared to the
more expensive
800 ipad pro and then later on
they can upsell customers on a magic
keyboard case
which likely has very high profit
margins
and if you're wondering why so many
people would want a magic keyboard case
let me get into the second reason why i
think it'll be so popular
apple has already announced a bunch of
new features and updates to ipad os
at their wwdc event but there's one
feature that i think is going to have
a massive impact on the ipad and it goes
hand in hand
with the magic keyboard case that
feature is keyboard and mouse gaming
coming to the ipad apple literally
created a developer tutorial video
on how to update current games with this
functionality
apple's reasons for adding keyboard and
mouse support is that there are
currently some game categories
which don't work very well with touch
support like vainglory
which is a moba game or basically any
first person shooter game
keyboard and mouse support gives you the
most amount of accuracy for playing
those types of games
and so far the magic keyboard case is by
far
the best choice if you're gonna use a
keyboard for playing games
all you have to do is connect a
bluetooth mouse and you've basically got
a gaming pc
with thousands of games on the ios app
store and i can tell you right now
once people start showing this
functionality off on youtube
sales of the magic keyboard case are
gonna go through the roof
especially since we're finally seeing
more great titles coming to the ipad
like call of duty mobile league of
legends apex legends and diablo immortal
apple's developer video showed off
features like custom pointers in games
and pointer locking so it doesn't bring
up the dock or the control center on
accident
so we know that it's going to work very
well they even showed off box 2 on the
magic keyboard case and it looked like
it worked
incredibly well thanks to the hardwired
connection
using the smart connector so there isn't
going to be any input lag
like you get with a bluetooth keyboard
now onto my third reason
apple is already planning on upgrading
the magic keyboard case in the future
with three features that are gonna be
huge just about a month and a half ago
apple was awarded a patent for another
magic keyboard case
except this time you'll be able to store
your apple pencil inside
of the hinge and it'll even recharge
while it's in there
it also looks like they've added another
usbc port on the side
but it's hard to tell if it'll handle
data transfer or not
but a very important new feature is the
addition of another hinge on the back
that can be used to get into higher
elevation mode
or a new clipboard mode which allows you
to fold the ipad down
to do things like take notes or draw and
when you fold it down
it'll even be able to launch your
favorite note-taking or drawing app
automatically these changes will be so
convenient
that there will most likely be a surge
in sales for those who use the apple
pencil
now if we consider everything that i
discussed in this video
including the upcoming ipad air 4.
there's a very good chance that the
magic keyboard case is going to break
into
a bunch of new markets like the massive
gaming market
and it's going to absolutely blow up
thanks to youtube and word of mouth
marketing
and i'm positive that very soon it's
going to become incredibly popular
just like the once overpriced airpods
now are
so if you want to see me testing out
keyboard and mouse gaming support once
it hits beta
then go ahead and click the circle above
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
that
and be sure to check out our new merch
right below this video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]